welcome back to the omr podcast Mr Scott
Galloway hi thanks for having me good to
be here
this time from London
yeah we moved here about eight months
ago
how come
you know it's uh it's the obvious
questions that are difficult to answer
so a variety of things we wanted to
um just from a personal standpoint we've
always wanted to live in another country
I've never lived in another country my
uh kids uh have never lived in another
country I wanted to give them the
exposure to something different my
parents originally from the UK so I've
always had felt a calling of it was just
loved Europe and five years ago we said
in five years we're moving to Europe and
it comes around and and we moved but I
wouldn't say there was any kind of event
if you will I I think the honest answer
is the reason we moved to London is
because we can
um we're blessed with the flexibility
and the resources to do something
wonderful so we did it and it's going to
be one year stand uh are you going to go
back soon
no I don't think it'll be one year
um my we enrolled our kids in school
here so
and they really are enjoying school and
my oldest is in ninth grade so I can't
imagine pulling him out of school to go
to a different school and I can't
imagine not living in the same country
as him so I would imagine we're here for
at least two or three years but you know
you never know when I moved to New York
I thought I'd be there for three years
and I was there 10 years and then
Florida was 10 years so
who knows but I imagine we're here for
at least a couple few years
we've talked about this before but I
mean many of the listeners probably
don't know but you have um strong
connections to Europe and especially
Germany anyways right
yeah well my wife was uh raised in
Germany and considers herself German
and I've always I've done a lot of work
in Germany you know the reality is if I
spoke German uh we probably would have
moved to Munich
um I I spend a lot of time in Germany
love it there and and my wife is German
so yeah we have strong connections with
Germany
so so what's your perspective now after
all this month in London and those Ties
on Europe and maybe especially on
Germany how do you see us
well I mean there's a big difference
it's sort of reductive to Carl to just
say Europe right because Greece is much
different than Ireland and the economies
the culture is just so
so different I would say that other than
just having really shitty weather my
observations of London are
just the incredible density of wealth
that has flowed in over the last several
decades I've been coming here two or
three times a year since I was five
and essentially London has had a
multi-trillion dollar facelift because
of private property laws that enable
anyone with capital to come here buy a
house and start you know doing business
here and whatever they bring in here is
kind of Untouchable by you know you can
be a war criminal and kind of come to
London and do your business here and
it's also established itself as sort of
the jumping out point to to Europe but
the British who seem to be outstanding
it snatching uh defeat from the jaws of
Victory brexit from an outsider
standpoint
every European nation has grown over the
last five years except for except for
the UK
and that is a direct function uh so uh
brexit so it seems like things were just
going a little too well for them and
they decided to to fix that Germany is
you know Germany is just sort of has
always been kind of the engine of Europe
and
what's always fascinating about Germany
is a reverence and respect for the
middle class
whether it's vocational programming 50
of people in Germany have some sort of
vocational certification versus only
five percent in the U.S
and uh and there's some you know that's
that's an amazing thing and then even
Boards of directors they mandate that a
certain number of people on your board
represent the workers so the result is
the income inequality hasn't been quite
as extreme in Germany the middle class
has done better you don't have the same
number of billionaires you don't have
the same number of you know runaway
successes
uh but it's it seems like it's more of a
I don't know many ways a healthier
a healthier model now the downside to
that
is that because the the downside isn't
as great that if you're an if you're a
talented kid coming out of high school
and you've got some abilities go to get
a vocational certification go to work
for an auto company you're going to have
a pretty decent life
whereas in the U.S the downside is much
greater the you do not want to be
without skills here in the U.S my father
who immigrated from Europe was said
America is a terrible place to be stupid
and when I thinking that was it's a
terrible place to be unmotivated because
we don't have the same safety net here
uh the downside to that is
entrepreneurship the culture of
Entrepreneurship just isn't as strong in
Germany would be my
assessment if you think about Germany I
think it's about double the size of 50
greater than the UK economy but the
United Kingdom has more
uh more unicorns and probably you know a
stronger startup scene in terms of at
least in terms of valuation
and so Germany because of I think more
of a risk aversion more of a uh it's a
more honorable path towards the middle
class which on the whole I think is a
good thing has resulted a lack of
incentive to take the kind of risks you
see in the UK much less the US and do
startups I've gotten to know the guys
from solonis
and I think right now that the second
most are the most valuable startup in
Europe and they'll probably be the best
biggest Tech IPO
in Europe for you know for a while if
and when it happens it'll probably
happen I would imagine I would guess in
2024 but
that is that could that could literally
jump start or re-jumpstart the startup
economy in Germany because typically
what happens is
you have a company that goes public and
creates billions or even hundreds of
billions in wealth and the people who
register that wealth uh are fond of that
City so they stay there they don't want
to work 60 hours a week they only want
to work 40 hours a week so they start a
venture capital firm and they start
seeding all sorts of startups and they
create an ecosystem it happened with
Dell and Austin it's obviously happened
over and over in the U.S and everywhere
from Boston
to you know North Carolina there's you
know there's kind of startups hubs that
have emerged everywhere but it hasn't
happened a lot in Europe so I think uh I
think you're going to see
uh probably not an explosion but an
increase
in startups just based on a few
companies that are doing very well in
Germany so obviously you're following
salonist um the munich-based company is
it also the reason why Munich is your
chosen city was your chosen City in case
you spoke German
no I I just met the guys from solanus
Recently I was just so blown away I I
was forwarded their numbers and in their
pitch deck and I was just so blown away
by their numbers that I I reached out to
them and and met with them just because
I was interested in learning more about
the company because I want to understand
more about the European tax system the
reason you know purely my interest in
Munich is I just think Munich's one of
the most beautiful livable cities in the
world and I got very close or did a lot
of work with the folks at Board of media
through the dld conference which I go to
every year
but um I just I just think Munich's a
world just from a lifestyle standpoint
and a place to visit I think Munich is
one of the most livable cities in the
world and I think Hamburg is one of the
coolest cities in the world it's like
Carl Lagerfeld exploded into a city it's
just the juxtaposition of
you know you see an enormous Crane and
Industry next to a beautiful
you know thousand euro per per square
foot condominium and All Glass it's just
it's like wallpaper magazine turned into
a city it's a really unique city
um
I enjoy Berlin because I like World War
II history I just think it's fascinating
and it's obviously got a very very kind
of interesting startup scene so yeah I'm
obviously a huge fan of Germany and the
other um German companies that you
follow a little bit I mean maybe listed
companies or private companies or
whatever
I'm trying to think I mean I a little
bit's Orlando just because they're in
the uh the e-commerce space but I
wouldn't say you know obviously sap the
Dutch company I forget what it's called
the chip maker that I think is the most
valuable company in Europe but I
wouldn't I'm not very well versed in the
German startup scene how about access
bringer I mean German company that's
trying to make some moves in the US
bring out my tier stuff another CEO yes
it's like purchasing American publishing
assets is that something you follow
yeah I know Matthias and I think he's a
great leader and I love the assets he
bought I think about Business Insider
which I think is a fantastic resource
and something I enjoy I think they also
bought Politico so yeah yeah Matthias
Matthias is a Visionary leader everyone
said he was overpaying for these assets
and it ends up that they have paid off
for him
uh so it's kind of nice to see an iconic
European company invading the U.S versus
Vice Versa but yeah I absolutely follow
it actual Springer does and there there
are just aren't that many traditional
meat companies with traditional media
routes who've been able to kind of make
the leap the digital so I mean they're
one of them he's he's done a great job
did you notice that there's a lot of
like public discussion here in Germany
concerning his role his opinions this
stuff has come out there's been reports
about private SMS that he sent with like
very controversial perspectives anything
that came to your attention
yeah I'd look I think that a lot of that
is just gossip I mean you're speaking
about the kind of the correspondence he
had with
um with Elon Musk and that's among other
things that's one but that's that's a
couple of others like here with the
former editor-in-chief of build the the
big tabloid so there's a lot going on
right now here in Germany
yeah look I I don't I I the honest
answer is I'm not that familiar with it
what I will say is that
um
the media the media is fascinated by
famous people and is always looking for
soft tissue to shed them in a poor light
also I will say that
um the media has a liberal bias
um and when a CEO is not
of that what I'll call woke culture I
think the media is more inclined to
report uh on it
um which is not a good or bad but I
think Matthias got caught in sort of a
I think people expect people from media
to be exceptionally Progressive and if
they reflect anything but a progressive
Viewpoint I think they're
um they get more scrutiny from other
media Outlets who are usually
traditionally pretty
pretty Progressive but I don't know
unless you're doing something illegal I
kind of feel as if you're taxed
are private and you know it just feels
kind of gossipy I mean I I wonder when
all my texts are going to come out and I
could imagine that people could you know
make me look like you know shed me in a
pretty poor light by cherry picking
certain Communications
what's your perspective on this
Progressive work culture in general I
mean I read an article in the Rolling
Stone magazine a couple days ago that
says like what they call Vogue companies
seem to be more successful even despite
the fact that that was expected for them
to be less successful now it seems the
opposite might be true but it's a it's a
very random sample
um there's a lot of discussion about
that and it's not very clear what woke
means but I'm sure you have an opinion
on that yeah I mean it's a complicated
topic because I consider myself a
progressive
I think you know the basics around
women's rights women having choice
making an effort and investing in a
society where people from different
backgrounds who traditionally haven't
had the same access or the same
opportunities that that is worth
investing and fighting for
and I think most Progressive values come
from what I'll call a good place
um there's definitely instances where
it's gotten out ahead of itself uh
universities where
students or faculty are shamed if they
don't demonstrate Progressive values you
know 97 of the faculty at Harvard
self-identify as Democrats
and universities are supposed to be
places of provocative thought and and
what my colleague Jonathan height
describes is everyone's barking up the
same tree that everyone's kind of
supposed to sign up for a narrative that
is usually a very Progressive narrative
and if they're not they're seen as quote
unquote dangerous and that is especially
upsetting in a university environment
where the whole point of a universe is
to be provocative and say quite frankly
what might seem at the time to be
offensive things
companies
companies that are I I think there's a
difference between correlation and
causation younger people are more
Progressive traditionally speaking in
urban cities and so if you the companies
that have added the most shareholder
value tend to be technology companies
which tend to be younger and tend to be
located in urban centers so they just
are going to initially draw from a
talent pool that is more Progressive
so I don't know if it's the progressive
values that is driving good outcomes or
just the fact that they attract people
that are more Progressive to begin with
um the
the where I think companies sometimes
make a mistake is I tell young people to
not bring your whole self to work I
don't think you should really discuss
politics at work and I think when CEOs
start discussing Progressive politics at
work oftentimes they're more virtue
signaling than they are really willing
to
Place resources around this and
unfortunately what it does is it trains
employees especially younger employees
that their political views have a role
at the company and I don't think that's
true I think corporations or
organizations or legal entities that are
constructed to help people establish
economic security for them and their
families in their beliefs and their
activities outside of work are their own
and shouldn't you know shouldn't
shouldn't fall under the scrutiny of the
organization and if you want to join the
NRA or you want to protest
um you know protest whatever cause it is
you're upset about or protest in favor
of it I think that's your business
but I think it's gotten to the point
where companies now feel as if they need
to take a stand politically
and a lot of people at the company feel
like to express their political
viewpoint
is their right and I think it's their
right but I don't think it's appropriate
in a lot of instances I think that
um I think it's dangerous to
um to have a company where people are
expected
to sign up for a certain political
ideology
um I think that's very personal I think
people should be able to have the
political Viewpoint they want and that a
corporation for the most part is there
to create economic value and economic
security for its employees so I wonder
if it's just gone gone a little too far
when you recently
um experienced some kind of I it looked
like at least
um controversy
involving Twitter I mean it seems like
um your Twitter account which is quite
large was shut down
yeah but to be fair I don't know if it
was shut down or that so many people
have been laid off that when I couldn't
get in and I sent in a customer service
um form or complaint that they just
don't have the people to respond I don't
to be honest I don't know if I'm
important enough that Elon Musk would
would take the effort to ban me so I
think I've noticed you I mean he knows
who you are he's I mean your other
critical perspectives quite frequently
on him and he's responded to some of
them already so he must know yeah he
does know me and he's calling names on
Twitter but I I don't know I think it I
think the most you know takam's razor
which is the most obvious explanation is
oftentimes the right explanation and I
think the most obvious explanation here
is there was a technical glitch I wasn't
able to log into my account I filled out
several forms online saying I can't log
in and it took them two and a half weeks
to fix the issue which is when you lay
off 80 of your staff it's understandable
or logical that customer service would
degrade substantially so that is what I
would guess happened I don't think it
was some Machiavellian effort to keep me
off of the platform
okay okay what's what's what's your
current perspective on on Twitter I mean
it looked very problematic in in the
first place now it seems like they're
maybe getting the turnaround
to go
I know I I think it's been a total
disaster
um he purchased it for 44 billion
dollars
um when the debt starts trading he was
he raised 13 billion in debt supposedly
the debt when it starts trading or when
the banks try and sell it it might trade
for 50 or 60 cents and if the debt
trades at 50 or 60 cents what the market
is saying is that
debt gets their money back first if the
company goes bankrupt so if the market
thought the company was worth 13 billion
dollars right now those bonds could be
sold at 100 cents on the dollar because
they get their money back first so if
they go out at 50 or 60 cents on the
dollar with the market is saying the
company's worth six to seven billion
dollars and he paid what 40 44 billion
or 42 billion just eight months ago so
in terms of value destruction
I don't think you've ever seen this type
of value destruction this quickly and a
lot of it is self-inflicted injuries the
company has lost
between somewhere between
60 and 70 percent of its ad revenues
and that's not because of the economy
that's not because they don't like the
ad stack or they don't like the product
it's because they don't like Elon Musk
and what they feel is really Reckless
Behavior
and so these are totally self-inflicted
wounds and I don't know if you saw the
BBC interview but
he claims he's kind of position himself
as saving it from bankruptcy this was a
company not headed towards bankruptcy I
mean it wasn't making money in some
years it was cash flow negative
but it had a 30 35 billion dollar market
cap it could have easily and it didn't
have any debt so it was not a
financially strained Company by coming
in and
and
behaving and what a lot of people felt
was a reckless manner you know
advertisers abandoned the platform and
mass and he put it into Financial stress
at Financial duress so and now he's
claiming it's like starting a fire in
your backyard and you pick up a hose and
you call yourself a hero
so this is a company that he has
dramatically downsized there's been very
little product Innovation the
subscription product is not working
I think he has demonstrated
a side of himself that is really ugly I
think it's going to hurt Tesla I sold my
Tesla I think there are a lot of people
who are less inclined to purchase a
Tesla now because of his
Antics in action and in just about the
same time a bunch of great electric
vehicles are coming on the market
including you know the i7 from from BMW
or the the Mercedes electric car is
incredible Volkswagen's coming for you
know the Electric market so I think
Twitter has been an unmitigated disaster
uh for for uh Elon Musk I can and anyone
who trusted him and invested into him
invested in this thing has seen
basically their Capital go up and smoke
this is already probably the second
worst acquisition in history just behind
uh aol's acquisition of Time Warner
do you feel like that Silicon Valley in
general has changed in in recent years I
mean people that that seem to run
Silicon Valley if you want and the most
dominant media Outlets that that we here
in Germany the the digital interested
people they now listen to the all-in
podcast for instance there's all kinds
of new voices coming out of Silicon
Valley it seems like there's a change
going on a little bit how do you see
that
yeah there's definitely I feel as if the
valley has kind of bifurcated into
Venture capitalists who see themselves
as part of a larger whole see themselves
as Citizens
um you know it was really kind of came
to light in the Silicon Valley Bank
crisis and that is you had hundreds of
venture capitalists who put together a
letter saying they would support the
bank and maintain their funds there
trying to facilitate An Elegant orderly
acquisition because they saw the bank
and the role the bank plate as being
important and they didn't want
um to see contagion spread to the
banking system
and what was more interesting than the
venture capitalist assignment letter was
the venture capitalist who did not sign
it
and uh those Venture capitalists many of
them have big investments in crypto and
web 3 technologies that to a certain
extent benefit
when America or the banking system is
under stress or duress and I call this
group of people Venture catastrophists
and some of them were on Twitter they
have very large followings in all caps
saying that there would be lines around
the banks most people would not get
their money back that the correct
response here was that you should be
terrified
and they were creating they were not
only going into a crowded theater but a
crowded stadium and screaming fire
and what I in the U.S our most patriotic
citizens are veterans people who have
served in uniform
and what strikes me is really
disappointing is some of our Most
Blessed Americans specifically people
who have typically got very good
educations have access to the most
robust uh technology and financing
ecosystem in the world have aggregated
enormous
uh wealth which translates to enormous
influence but they don't seem to be very
patriotic they would rather see the
banking system go down such that their
Bitcoin Investments go up they talk
about
um they're kind of um bunkers and plans
to either colonize Mars or go take us
into the metaverse as opposed to taking
their genius and their capital and
trying to make the you know the planet
were on more habitable
so I think there's sort of this Venture
catastrophist libertarian
anti-American vein running through
technology that's very disappointing
that you would think that these people
would feel more loyalty and gratitude
towards the United States as opposed to
sort of betting on its demise and
constantly
you know I say posting America you
know Elon Musk says his General view is
the government should just get out of
way and he's openly disdainful of
government meanwhile he's taken billions
of dollars from the government whether
it's for charging stations or for a 350
million dollar loan
for his company when it was not doing
well his NASA contracts I mean he is he
he has taken more money from the
government than than most companies and
at the same time he'll call for a pause
on AI because of the risks it presents
and then it comes out that he's in fact
buying all sorts of equipment to try and
Implement AI or Twitter and that he's
Incorporated to do a new startup with
Twitter uh a new startup in AI it just
feels as if this community has not done
itself any favors that there's a general
feeling that they're not
yeah they're not very patriotic and
they're not concerned that their
interests have diverged from the
interests of you know kind of the
broader well-being
of the United States
would you say that Elon Musk for
instance net net is is
positive for for Society for the world
or negative
I think it's a positive
um I think that the he I don't think he
can
I think you have to acknowledge that he
inspired the EV race
and the world is better off for that
we're going to reduce carbon emissions
in America mostly because the infamous
excuse me the climate bill that Biden
passed but
you know Germany which makes in my view
the best cars in the world has Elon Musk
has absolutely
you know motivated German automakers to
go much faster towards EV so he's
motivated the entire planet to move
towards the east that's a huge positive
for the world uh space exploration
um I think or not even space exploration
but space hauling isn't a big positive
for the world it creates a lot of value
I've share all their value
so I would say isn't that positive I
feel the same way about tech the problem
is with the word net
and that is fossil fuels have been a net
positive for the world but we still have
emission standards pesticides have been
a net positive for the world but we
still have regulation around you know
the Food and Drug Administration
what we don't do around technology or
someone like Elon Musk is we've decided
they're either good or bad and you have
to be all in and worship them or think
they're evil as opposed to the
definition of intelligence is you can
hold two thoughts in your mind at the
same time and it is you can acknowledge
his incredible Talent the good he's done
and acknowledge that he deserves a lot
of rewards for it I think it's the
second or third wealthiest man in the
world but at the same time hold them
accountable when he starts accusing his
employees of sex crimes which is just
not true
you know hold them accountable when he
circulates misinformation around
violence to get against the husband of
the speaker of the house here in the
United States speculating that it would
have some sort of gay scandal
yeah these these statements uh create
put these people in tangible danger they
they they ruin people's lives or they
make their lives much harder and when
you're an individual who is of this
powerful you would you would expect them
to behave more responsibly you would
expect them to acknowledge or at least
recognize the power they have
and show a little bit more grace and
quite frankly just a little bit more
maturity
so is he a net positive yes has he done
ridiculously Reckless childish stupid
things yes uh and I think we can hold
both of those thoughts in our mind at
the same time